joe just out of curiosity who have you
debated who's been your toughest debate
ever
i mean
i didn't feel that any of my debates
were tough i've owned
i
i'm
yeah
who have you debated
in 1996 i was in the third party debate
when i debated the green party
constitution party and and those
uh in march before
the nomination
i was also in a third party debate where
i sat next to the green party
nominee and a few other people and then
of course the debates within the
libertarian party
but when's the last time you had a
really tough debate against a
non-libertarian when is it
it was pretty easy uh debating the green
party candidate that's for sure um
so
yeah let me continue when is the last
time you had a debate with a
non-libertarian or non-green party
when's the last time you had a debate
with somebody that was non-libertarian
non-green well an official debate like i
said it would be in the nomination
process in 2020
20 19 20 who'd you debate
well as i said the the green party i
don't remember who all was on the stage
uh some of them are parties i'd never
heard of but i have heard of the green
party and then um in 2020 it was within
the party so you've never debated
anybody that's uh opposing libertarian
or green party
well i mean again like if i come to
american party
i want to google it right i'm on youtube
right now if i type in joe jorgensen
debate
what would you say is the part debate
that you had
that
was either a democrat or republican or
an independent oh there was a democrat
or two in the debate in chicago in
march
yeah i guess it would have been march
2020.
who who were they when you debated them
i don't remember their names was it
was it a stage debate was it public was
it oh yeah it was in it was in chicago
and what was the format what was the
format of the debate uh
we would go down the line and answer
questions and get to respond to each
other but that's not a debate though so
you've never well
i mean you know it's not like the
lincoln douglas were debated so it
wasn't
uh are you planning on running in 2023
2024 i don't know okay so let's just say
you are
uh
who who is your who is your like
um
who
behind closed doors are they sitting
there and like you know going back and
forth to assets you say this if they say
this you say this like who does that
with you guys back and forth debating do
you guys practice a lot of that
well since i was in no debates in
after the nomination we didn't do it
we were invited to the third party
debate however
i we were on the ballot in all 50 states
and
so
i did not want to debate
the other parties because that would get
us into comparison with them as opposed
to the democrats and republicans
if i debated the green party then for
the next four weeks i'd have
reporters asking me to compare you know
what what about this on the debate stage
and now compare this
and the libertarian party is the only
party other than the democrats and
republicans to be on the ballot in all
50 states
uh there and so i i'm not going to
debate the green party or kanye west
who's on 16 states i actually probably
would get you more eyeballs if you
debated kanye west i think that would be
a good debate that actually might not be
a bad idea but going back to it so
um
so debating you so who's been your
toughest interview
who has interviewed the toughest and
pushed you where you got off saying what
a son of a [ __ ]
in the past yes
toughest interview ever
where you couldn't wait to finish the
interview
oh that would have been in 1996 when i
was running for a vp and i interviewed
somebody in ohio but i don't remember
the guy's name it's a long time ago it
is it's a long time ago that's like
saying you want to be a heavyweight
champion today but the last time you
fought a heavyweight was 26 years ago
you know how tough that is well no you
didn't ask when's the last time i fought
a heavyweight that was the last time
because i wasn't as prepared in 1996. so
who's the last heavyweight you fought
who's your last heavyweight you found oh
like who interviewed me yeah who's the
toughest interview you've had recently
well but again i wouldn't call it tough
but uh you know
the washington post i mean i i did i got
interviewed by several media people but
i didn't consider them tough yeah so uh
okay so so for me the reason why i asked
that question is because
um
i said i've sat with other libertarians
and for somebody who politically was on
a different side and i sit down let me
hear the libertarian argument
and
you know i'm like oh okay that makes
sense oh okay well you know what that's
a good point you got me thinking oh wow
okay you know what never thought about
it i never looked at drugs that we've i
never looked at prostitution that way
before i never looked at you know
stealing that way before interesting
okay cool it made me think right
and and i don't feel i asked well so
the meth house didn't make you think
the idea that okay if we had phil morris
making meth instead of the guy next door
that that would be safer isn't that
maybe something you haven't heard
and we didn't get into prostitution but
hey i think i was pretty unique saying
that i don't want to discriminate
against ugly guys i mean right now to do
it legally you have to have money or you
have to be good-looking right
to get the woman that you want with her
looks are you are you i think that's you
are you open to feedback can i give
feedback okay
so if if i if i wanted to give you
feedback
here's what i would do
i would sit you down
in a room like this
for four weeks straight
and i would grill the hell out of you
until you were throwing stuff at me oh
absolutely yeah and you would throw
stuff at me because i know how to do
that
and you would say pat i need a break i'd
say no prom go forward take a break come
back
okay
dr joe we role play this i'm going to
ask a question one more time what are
your points boom
and i would i would go back and forth
back and forth back and forth because
there's a difference between the big
stage and between debating other
libertarians i mean what is the debate
with a libertarian look like okay i
agree with him yeah i agree with him but
i also agree with him but what i would
say is this but i think the age is 19
but i think they should be 18 but i
think the border should be this but i
think that but i agree but i agree but i
agree i mean the most important one time
we had a debate uh tyler who was a
debate we had with the two marijuana
folks that we had here debating
yeah and then no no it wasn't even that
it was that the beta had between alan
dershowitz and the other gentleman who
wrote the vaccine and then 20 minutes
into i'm like guys why don't we just
finish this debate and guys go have
dinner together because every word is i
agree i agree i agree nobody wants to
see something like that people want to
learn on opposing ideas to sit there and
say that doesn't make any sense if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]